Hi, Mystery Recapped here.
Today I am going to explain the science fiction
drama film called “Mr. Nobody.”
Spoilers ahead!
Watch out and take care!
The movie is set in the year 2092.
Humanity has conquered mortality through the
endless renewal of cells.
An 118-year-old man named Nemo is the last
mortal left on earth.
Everyone else on earth is quasi-immortal and
no longer suffers from illnesses and aging.
This has come at a cost and these quasi-immortal
humans can no longer procreate.
Although he is evidently older, Nemo insists
that he is 35 years old and was born in the
year 1975.
Scientists, researching life before humans
attained immortality, believe that Nemo has
lost his memory.
With no recollection and written records of
his past anywhere, people start calling Nemo
Mr. Nobody.
He spends his life under 24/7 surveillance
and people vote every week to decide whether
he should be allowed to naturally pass away
or artificially kept alive.
Curious to know Nemo’s past, a psychiatrist
named Dr. Feldheim uses hypnosis to help him
recall some of his memories.
The hypnosis helps Nemo access his subconsciousness
reaching as far back as the time even before
his conception.
While Dr. Feldheim is away, a journalist sneaks
into the facility where Nemo is kept and takes
his interview.
Nemo reveals to the journalist that all unborn
babies reside in heaven and remember everything
that can happen in their future and how it
can be altered if they make certain choices.
However, before they are born, the angels
of Oblivion erase their memory.
Somehow, the Angels forget about Nemo, allowing
him to "remember" different possible futures
for himself.
This means that the present day 118-year-old
forgetful Nemo can recall his different probable
pasts and among one of them is the actual
life he led.
Nemo further reveals that the babies get to
choose their parents and he chose his mother
because she smelled nice.
Nemo took birth with the ability to foresee
all possible futures.
At age 9, he tells his mother about the Angels
of oblivion.
He correctly predicts that his father’s
car will get out of control and kill a lady.
However, Nemo’s mother doesn’t believe
him and tells him that one can only see the
past, not the future.
Nemo’s mother is justified to think so.
Some 13.7 billion years ago, our universe,
which was then smaller than a proton, exploded
and started rapidly expanding.
After the big bang, three spatial and one
temporal dimensions were deployed.
While the spatial dimension allowed us to
freely travel within what we know as width,
height and depth, the temporal dimension doesn’t
offer that same freedom.
The arrow of time as we know it only moves
in one direction and it’s most evident proof
is that we can only see our past and not see
our future.
So, if Nemo is able to see the future that
would mean that time can be reversed, which
we haven’t witnessed yet.
At the park, Nemo acquaints three girls from
his neighbourhood Anna, Elise and Jean.
One day, Nemo notices his mother walking into
the woods by herself.
He follows her and sees her cheating on his
father with another man.
The infidelity eventually comes to light and
Nemo’s parents have a huge fight which ends
in devorce.
They go their separate ways and poor Nemo
is forced to choose one of his parents as
his mother leaves on a train while his father
stays on the platform.
In one instance, Nemo decides to board the
train with his mother and move to Canada while
in another he stays with his father.
In the instance where he leaves with his mother,
Nemo becomes a rebellious teenager.
He tries his best to scare her mother’s
boyfriend Harry away.
Meanwhile, Nemo’s dad meets with an accident
and becomes disabled.
At school, Nemo notices a new girl Anna and
is instantly smitten by her.
One day, Anna approaches him on the beach
and asks him if he would like to swim with
her and her friends.
However, Nemo rudely declines her, telling
her he doesn’t swim with idiots.
Offended, Anna leaves and they barely see
each other again.
Two decades pass by and Nemo one day runs
into Anna with her two kids at the train station.
They awkwardly greet each other before parting
ways and Nemo regrets insulting Anna at the
beach when he was young.
Nemo again revisits his choice at the beach
and when Anna approaches Nemo at the beach,
he truthfully admits to her that he cannot
swim.
The two then spend time together.
Few days pass by.
Nemo isn’t able to fend off his mother’s
boyfriend.
Harry moves in with him and his mother with
his daughter.
It turns out that Anna is Harry’s daughter,
making Nemo her step brother.
Nemo and Anna have mutual disgust for their
parents' relationship and overtime get romantically
close to each other.
Nemo starts sneaking into Anna’s room at
night behind his mother’s back.
Eventually, Nemo’s mother and Harry find
out about the step-siblings' affair and decide
to separate to break them up.
Nemo and Anna are heartbroken by the news.
Anna makes Nemo promise to wait for her at
the lighthouse every Sunday until they see
each other again.
Anna moves to New York with her father.
Nemo waits for Anna at the lighthouse for
months but never meets her while Anna sends
him letters but Nemo’s mother hides them
from Nemo and eventually they both lose touch.
Nemo becomes more and more distant from his
mother.
Two decades pass by.
Nemo still dearly remembers Anna.
He works as a pool cleaner, hoping to one
day run into Anna who loves swimming.
Eventually, they finally see one another at
the train station and immediately recognize
each other in a crowd of passers-by.
The two embrace each other and passionately
make up for the time they lost.
Anna tells him while she was kept away from
him, she had vowed that she would never love
anyone else ever.
She never became attached to anyone.
She had nothing for herself.
She only pretended to be alive.
This moment is what she has been waiting for
all this time.
She renounced all possible lives and loves
for him.
However, she adds that she is not used to
love anymore.
She is terrified of losing him again and go
through the hell she went through when they
were separated at 15.
She tells him that she needs more time.
Anna gives him her number, asks him to call
her in two days and meet at the lighthouse.
However, he loses her number when a sudden
downpour makes her note illegible.
Nemo waits at the lighthouse every day, but
Anna does not come.
In a different storyline, Anna and Nemo get
married and have children.
He works as a host of a TV show, which explains
various scientific phenomena.
One evening, while driving home from work,
Nemo hits a bird and loses control of his
car.
The out of control car plummets into a lake
and Nemo drowns.
Meanwhile, in a similar yet alternate version
of events, Nemo works at the same television
studio but isn’t married to Anna.
Moreover, Nemo’s assistant crashes into
the lake and drowns instead of him.
At the funeral, Nemo meets Anna who is revealed
to be his assistant's widow.
With none of these life paths ending happily,
Nemo explores the life he would have led had
he chosen to stay with his father.
In this instance as well, Nemo’s father
meets with an accident and becomes disabled.
Nemo starts working at a local shop when he
is not in school or taking care of his father.
In his leisure time, he likes riding bikes
and writing science fiction stories about
a journey to Mars at home on his typewriter.
At a school party, Nemo meets a girl named
Elise and develops feelings for her.
However, he freezes in front of her.
When Elise encourages him to say something,
the nerd starts talking about Mars.
Elise laughs at his nerdiness and makes him
swear that when she dies, he will spread her
ashes on mars.
Some days later, he goes to Elise’s house
to ask her out but he sees her with her ex-boyfriend
Stefano.
Frustrated, he speeds away on his motorcycle
and meets with an accident that sends him
into a vegetative state.
Though he can perceive the world through his
senses, Nemo cannot move or speak.
He senses his parents' reunion at his bedside.
Nemo tries to remember the movement of his
fingers on the typewriter keyboard and eventually
manages to lift a finger as this story line
comes to a close.
Nemo again reverses back to the time when
he saw Elise with Stefano.
This time after Stefano leaves, Nemo approaches
Elise and professes his love for her.
Elise breaks into tears and confesses that
she is in love with Stefano but he doesn’t
love her back.
Elise then politely rejects him and leaves.
Once again heartbroken, Nemo vows to marry
the first girl who will dance with him at
the school prom.
That night, he meets a cute girl named Jean
and dances with her.
While returning home with her, Nemo takes
several pledges.
He vows to marry Jean and become rich and
successful.
Years pass by.
Nemo has a beautiful wife, two children and
a big house but he is still unhappy with his
life.
After feeling discontent with his destination
despite having planned his life, Nemo starts
making all of his decisions randomly via coin
toss.
He writes over all his possessions to Jean
and leaves his family.
At the airport, the coin leads him to pretend
to be a passenger named Daniel Jones, who
is taken to a hotel by a waiting chauffeur.
In Daniel’s hotel room, Nemo is murdered
by two assassins who mistake him for Daniel
Jones.
Nemo again revists the time when he was at
Elise’s house.
Nemo learns that Elise is in love with her
ex-boyfriend but he does not back down and
convinces her to give him a chance.
Few years pass by and the two get married.
In one version of the storyline, Elise dies
in a blast shortly after they get married.
Fulfilling his promise, Nemo keeps her ashes
and embarks on a journey to Mars.
While returning back to earth after spreading
Elise’s ashes on the planet’s surface,
Nemo meets Anna aboard the spacecraft.
However, before they can say much to each
other, the ship is destroyed by meteoroids.
In an alternate version of events, Nemo and
Elise are married with three children.
However, Elise is suffering from several borderline
personality disorder and chronic depression.
She frequently experiences panic attacks and
despite Nemo’s several attempts to save
their marriage, Elise ultimately leaves him
to pursue Stefano.
While running through all the paths he could
take or has taken, Nemo time and again wakes
up in a surrealistic world that seems like
a movie set, possibly indicating that it is
not a possible path of Nemo’s life.
Nemo follows several clues he finds scattered
throughout the city and ultimately reaches
a crumbling, abandoned wooden-framed house.
Inside, he finds a DVD player hooked up to
a television screen.
In the oddly interactive video, the 118-year-old
Nemo converses with the 34-year-old one.
The older Nemo explains that the life the
younger Nemo is living is the older Nemo’s
past and therefore time is inverted for him.
The older Nemo further reveals that the younger
Nemo doesn’t exist in this particular universe
because in this universe Nemo Nobody was never
born and it is all the possible life paths
being played in the mind of the unborn baby
Nemo’s consciousness in heaven.
The older Nemo states that he is experiencing
the story from the end and that he must stay
alive until 5:50 AM on 12 February 2092.
After hearing all of the possible storylines,
the journalist becomes confused as to which
story is the actual past of the 118 year old
Nemo.
Nemo tells him that each one of these are
the right ones.
Each path is the right path.
The response puzzles the journalist even more
and he asks Nemo how he can exist after dying.
He wonders if there’s something called afterlife.
Nemo laughs him off and asks him how he can
be sure if he even exists.
Nemo then goes on to tell him that neither
of them exist.
They are figments in the mind of the 9-year-old
Nemo at the train station, as he was forced
to make an impossible choice.
In order to find the correct decision, the
young boy follows each choice to its conclusion.
However, after going through all of his options,
it has become even more difficult for young
Nemo to make his decision.
Nemo ultimately decides to take the third
option: to not make the choice at all.
He leaves both parents and runs away towards
an unknown future.
Sometimes in chess the only viable move is
not to move.
All the instances that were playing in Nemo’s
head begin to crumble as he has made his decision
clear.
The movie cuts back to the old Nemo on his
deathbed.
Just before he passes away, Nemo recalls his
reunion with Anna and recites Anna’s name.
It is revealed that Anna ultimately came to
the lighthouse and reunited with Nemo.
This version of Nemo’s life and all events
that lead to it were the real ones.
Now, the question remains, how was Nemo able
to see the future?
Lo and behold, at 5:50 AM, the expansion of
the universe comes to a halt and it begins
to contract, resulting in reversal of time.
The Universe is undergoing a Big crunch.
After expanding for billions of years from
a small point of singularity to billions of
light-years in diameter, the gravitational
forces have finally counterbalanced the forces
of expansion i.e., the dark energy.
Just like the temporal dimension was opened
after the big bang, it is now being closed
during the retraction of the universe.
Time is reverting.
Consequently, Nemo is able to return to his
childhood, watch his parents get back together
and be with Anna.
The 118-year-old man cackles triumphantly
as he springs back into awareness with the
realization that his younger self has finally
found his one true love and life.
Make sure to subscribe and turn on the notifications
so you can watch more videos like this.
Thanks for watching.